yeah but then you might get stretch
marks in other places should i finally
tell people what my butt is made out of
honestly i want to know i haven't been
like over you have the nicest ass yeah
that's what i want to know because
everyone is good okay do you want to
know like the progression of my ass yeah
so first the bbl
did absolutely nothing besides put marks
on my body
super bad i do not recommend it if
you're a skinny girl
second i flew to atlanta georgia with my
friend stephanie at the time and we got
illegal butt injections
in a hotel room oh my god we flew to
atlanta but we went to somewhere called
alpharetta stayed at like a motel seven
something like that oh [ __ ] there's
emotions a woman came
with like giant horse needles and a jug
of silicone it was literally like a huge
ass jug it was like oily like oil but it
was silicone
and horse needles like this big i think
i already said that
and she'd be like no painkillers nothing
and she'd be like just lay on the bed
and then she put little dots like on our
butts where she was going to inject it
and i'm talking about maybe like 20
injections with this huge horse needle
and you just sit there sober with her
injecting your ass
the pain was so bad but i was me and my
girlfriend at the time we were so
desperate because we both had very
straight bodies like no hips nothing i
was like top heavy before so i wanted to
be like more womanly you know
so that was like my second i did that
two times my butt was way too big after
the second time about a year ago i got
part of my ass literally chopped off
i know i never got to see the we were
talking about it one day yeah
i never got to see
since i was legit 15 years old i've been
saying i wanted butt injections to my
mom to everyone i used to google in
indiana i'd be like in home in bed at
night it'd be 10 p.m
googling the price of butt injections
and it was like there was like ten
thousand it's like i'm going to save up
every penny
and me
i'm
we'll buy me a car one day i swear to
god
that guy will buy you a car with the
knife that you have
guys i'm not condoning like uh illegal
butt injections but i have to say like
the procedures put out by actual doctors
they don't look good but implants know
like it looks [ __ ] horrible bbl if
you're a skinny girl they're literally
just gonna take your money scar you up
no your butt's not gonna be bigger but
injections i have to say my experience
was pretty good besides the fact that i
made it way too big and again like i'm
not condoning it it's extremely
dangerous but i just don't think in the
legal market there is like a good
alternative well my question is so you
can legally get butt injections so
what's the difference now there's
hyaluronic acid but injections that cost
like ten thousand dollars a session and
they do pretty much nothing like your
butt's gonna look the same okay how do
they fade away after a while right yeah
they're saying their lips and stuff
it'll be yeah they're not permanent also
like even for that price you're not
going to see like a result for the
amount that they're giving you for that
price because hyaluronic acid injections
are so expensive so how did you even
find
the illegal ones like how did you google
how she's like can you give me her
content i am like yeah
actually yeah we want to know i'm like
booking my flight to jordan i mean i
personally won't share her contact just
because it's extremely illegal and if
you're affiliated with someone who
gets it done and they happen to die i
would be charged with manslaughter so
that's why i don't share the contact
with anyone like i want you all to have
amazing beautiful butts because you're
gonna have to find it yourself because
i'm not she's a worker no i'm just
saying general before you even found her
what did you do type it in on google no
no so you have to know someone yeah yeah
like you would have to work probably and
like get the contacts
yeah and then you have to have a
reference for her to even like respond
to you
crazy yeah because she doesn't want to
like get arrested like it's illegal yeah
that's crazy
what are your thoughts
there's a couple of things that pass
through my mind
okay first thing first
i pop a free call to honeys i'm just
kidding
the first thing is just
first and foremost
we shouldn't be commenting on this
because this is the patriarchy
that's what i hear that's what i did
there's a lot of there's a lot of
disciples about that the fact that you
know body you should leave people that
have body transformation alone that's
part of who they want to be and this and
that and we should have no say about
that because it's the standards that was
but put on by the patriarchy that makes
it so you're part of the patriarchy and
you're part of that
calm down second thing that goes to my
mind is that i i know some of these
girls that have experiences like that
and that says i don't know what's in
i don't know what's in the wax
when you do this [ __ ] illegally to me
like you don't know what even when you
do it legally you don't know what's in
the those injections that they're giving
you
you know the first main ingredient but
you don't know the other ingredients but
it's all good i'm not for that i don't
know what they put in your body i'm like
do you know what you put in your body
like
whatever i digress it's just really
funny to me bruh you can't put a legal
bun jackson you and your auntie back
[ __ ]
it's like the people was like yeah but
uh i really like to like take care of my
body uh that's why i'm vegan you should
be vegan too and then snort cocaine on
the weekend and then i'm like bruh you
snort cocaine on the weekend and they
like that but cocaine is vegan
like jeffy that's not the point it's not
good for your body
anyways
listen linda
clean skin is the first thing that
people see when they meet you
your business card your money maker your
wow factor you want to have clean skin
and t henley has a thing for you if you
feel a bit lost with this you don't know
where to start it's okay t.h henley has
a level one skin care system in that
system you have instruction that gives
you the frequency what products to use
the when the how you don't even have to
think easy peasy lemon squeezy face
cleaning that's what it is so order your
skin care system today by th handling
the level 1 skin care system includes
products such as a daily face wash ain't
nobody got time to walk around with dirt
and grime on their face also the daily
facial moisturizer that has spf
20 on it because you don't want to burn
your skin out there skin cancer is a
real thing and the two times per week
scrub facial scrub
to get all the little particles out of
your pores so if you're ready to have
clear skin go in the link in the
description below and order your box and
you'll get a free gift on us
it's really me all right it's not really
yabba it's really me because i'm the
skincare guy right you're on your way to
clean skin and you got a gift boom that
there's that there's oh it's a lot
it's more than you think
there's a lot of people out there it's
in this cheese i got some of my people
that went to colombia there were some
people that went to cuba that wanted to
get these because it's cheaper cheaper
doesn't necessarily look better and then
people think that you get butt
injections or all these stuff like that
and then your burden is like you are
good
you need to train
if the butt don't match the thigh we
gonna know
it looks ridiculous at some point it
does
it does look a little bit ridiculous you
look at it you're like wow you got two
whole cakes in the back but no legs
it just goes straight i didn't like i
had no hips so i want a little bud so
and then you're gonna put that [ __ ] on
and then this still looks ridiculous
because the the butt don't match the
thigh it's crazy and the last thing i'm
gonna say is like it's funny still funny
like i'm from another era and all those
things
they used to laugh at us for it
everybody want to be black but don't
really want to be black they used to
make fun of girls with big butt i used
to love a girl with big bucks
[ __ ] i still do
but they used to laugh at them huh you
got a bit but remember when it was only
titties
there was only big titty meat that was
the thing
and then no but now they replicate that
remember when they used to laugh about
our
lips and they make the [ __ ] noises
talking about baboons and [ __ ] like that
when the baboons really don't have no
lips it really looks like you but that's
another story it's just crazy everything
that they used to laugh at us for
now they're trying to take the tan
they used to laugh at her tan now
they're trying to tan they used to laugh
at their butts now they get button
sessions they lose a lot they used to
laugh at our lips now they're getting
lipstick injection i'm pretty sure the
next train is going to be big nose look
i got that brazilian nose done
it's gonna be just flared up you know
what i mean that's
it's a lot but that's pretty much what i
think there's a lot of funny things in
that video that's why i chuckle a bit
and i think about it because they go
through my mind what do you think about
that
some people might watch and they're like
why would you go through all this
trouble to do all that
like it's just gross but i'm like you've
been on instagram
it's actually a really smart investment
if you want to make money you want like
return on your investment
forget a bitcoin you get yourself a nice
ass you can get a really good return on
the best absolutely
and there is something interesting where
dudes will sometimes get mad and like
yell at women like this but then they
follow the same women on instagram
literally contributing to their wealth
and their following and their growth
yeah
that's always a weird thing it's a weird
way we would think i like your natural
and then you look at the feet of the
dude and like bruh none of what you
follow is natural yeah yeah and so you
you think about these beauty stands we
also have to understand how we're
complicit and at the same time if you
tell a lot of these ladies you know
the most things that we're going to
value for your looks
and that's how you're going to get ahead
don't be surprised when they invest a
lot in their looks either you know
me personally am i a fan not really i
think you know if you start cutting
yourself up to feel good about yourself
i don't know if that's going to be a
really good
way to live life long term
but at the same time it's kind of part
of the the way we've set up
we've just overvalued big asses told
everyone if they don't have it they
should probably feel insecure because
that's all we like
well some people don't want to live with
that insecurity they might try to fix it
i'm not advocating for them i think it's
a good thing hell no but you understand
it's not surprising it's inevitable it's
not surprising it's inevitable look at
you turning into a whole preach it's not
surprising
you're not the only one who can be not
surprised by them i know yeah yeah so
don't put put that as a preaching yeah i
put it as a priest thing i'm rejecting
that i'm not i'm not a preacher yeah
that's a pretty thing
but anyways you made it a preach thing
no
this is every time we would start a
video you're like i'm not surprised i'm
like hey we heard you the first 50 times
we got the point
after a while i was like okay we got it
you're never surprised see your reaction
not surprised
but um
but
sorry
yeah it's um
if you if you already know like bbl's in
general some of the most dangerous
procedures you can get done
and people will still go under the knife
and still do it
and the worst part is for a lot of these
ladies it's not even a financial
investment it's just a self-esteem like
yes
that's the dumb ones to me that's a dumb
so if you at least gonna make money off
the ass i could understand
the ones who just do it for self-esteem
reasons i'm like good lord you don't
know what it's like out there what
you don't know how it's like how hard it
is to be a woman
with no self-esteem
and it works maybe maybe it's because
dudes is slightly different
but as a man
you can't respect the dude who had like
surgically implanted biceps
no
or or what's what's the name of them not
ethanol
there's there's some yeah i know exactly
which one you're talking about
ridiculous
ridiculous but the thing the thing as
well is is
if
even if the procedure is not dangerous
getting something in your body is
having silicone in your body
can give you cancer
and i have it happen to one of my good
friends
she
she did a boot job
there was a defect they never told her
they never did the recall yeah
got cancer yeah starting to have weird
things happening in their body
remove the boobs
everything's fine
you have to be careful you have to be
super careful
it's dangerous yes
so that's a little discriminator you
guys don't travel to georgia for this
all right even though a lot of you are
still going to do it but guys understand
the stuff that you follow and you put
money into
understand the message and if it does if
it can contradict with your other values
it's like
this is one of those things that i find
it's interesting but let me know what
you guys think in the comments below
we'd like to hear from you